by the way it's like kryptonite in the
club so clubs really are like huntin
grounds though so that guys did I mean
why do guys go there because that's
where the prey is it's like gravity
here's a good test for your size and
check out guys really thank you thank
you oh yeah this is my first time ever
doing an open mic I'm very nervous thank
you sir you're very funky and the
nervousness I'm feeling right now is
similar to when it's happening right now
I'm looking at girls in the audience and
I get really nervous around girls easily
like what's your name I forget your name
I'm sorry man brass max okay brass would
have been a little cooler Max is like
he's really confident and charming and I
haven't even really talked to the guy
but if I could be just a little bit like
you that would be incredible if I was a
girl or you know gay guy which some
people think I am for some reason benign
but nothing wrong with that I would
still pursue you tell you at the end of
the day but yeah I was driving here
today on the 405 which is the best
freeway on the planet I everyone loves
the 405 I think the 405 is something
kind of beautiful if you really think
about it you know if you get into
traffic and we're really divided nation
yeah but went under the 405 everyone is
in everyone just hates the 405 like when
you're on the traffic is just boring in
general I don't know anyone who's like I
can't wait to commute to work today to
go to traffic this is really exciting in
my life and all those optimist out
they were like oh yeah you know is the
new traffic it's a good time to be by
myself you know like a listen to some
music
you're just in denial of how bored you
really are
that's all I'm gonna say on that okay
but know when you're like in traffic it
does get incredibly boring and it's
never a good time to be in traffic
especially when they're doing
construction on the freeway like when
you're doing construction on the freeway
it's never a good time for you in the
car
you don't think about the better good
about when the best time is for them to
do construction you're just like this is
ridiculous
why now it could be 9:00 in the morning
and you could be like but doing this on
the way to work everyone has to go to
work in the morning be 5 o'clock and you
could be like I gotta get home from work
and there's all this traffic then you
like 2:00 in the morning and you're like
but they know that people have late jobs
and they have to get out there at 2:00
in the morning
this is they're treating us horribly
it's just local and you know like right
now I'm pretty broke which I just
started dating someone which kind of
sucks because I or $10 already I'm off
to a great start there she's one of the
performers by the way I'm not gonna say
who she is but she's really hot she's
the one laughing at all my jokes right
now great supporter but yeah it's I
sometimes drive on the freeway and then
the gas light comes on and you're stuck
in traffic and then you know the exits
not for like another 30 minutes for some
reason and you don't want to be that guy
in truck because whenever there's a car
stopper there's a car accident and you
know that's what's happening way up
ahead all you're thinking is why is
everyone stopping right now to look at
the car accident and we've all seen car
accidents before but the second you get
up to the car well the second you get up
to the accident you're likely something
you're looking at then you find yourself
slowing down to look at the traffic
you're doing everyone else is doing
so really we're all similar we're all in
common and I don't have everything guys
been broke before Yeah right this
community that's what I'm talking about
there's a community out there and being
broke can be kind of funny sometimes in
order to know what it's like to be broke
you have to know what it's like to first
acquire money and then lose all your
looks like in that if it works out early
they all know how this goes you you
basically go up you you get to sorry you
said two minutes I thought it may be the
peace sign and I was like so where was I
being broke yeah when you're broke and
you can working an hourly job and you
find yourself you know you get like a
fifty dollar extra paycheck on that day
you know you make 800 bucks they got 850
and for some reason our brains go wow I
got a lot of extra money right now I
could totally spend all of this and then
three days later it's all gone you're
like my money you go on your online
banking you're like deducting everything
should have caught that day like I did
not even bite that much McDonald's like
it was ridiculous and you go out for
drinks with your friends I take care of
you guys then there's like other weird
stuff that you know I buy that I can't
talk about because we just got reminded
about censorship up here I'm gonna watch
myself but if you're looking at me and
you're like this guy looks like he's in
weird things you are probably right
about whatever is conjuring up in your
mind right now but yeah it's you ever
have a bad hair day like you wear a hat
and then you're like well my hat my hair
looks kind of good when I put the hat on
it and I notice my bad hair days are
always on the days where I need my hair
to look really good
it's didn't my hair looks great like
right before I'm about to go to sleep
and then I find myself like going I want
to go out now
I want people to see how good my hair
looks at this very moment as I feel
confident and I could be like gnats or
flat brass max hey I just did poetry is
that cool awesome all right thank you
guys
first time performing comedy and here
everybody for Ryan right